there's a lot of [ __ ] that we got to
talk about but in all seriousness the
[ __ ] thing is the one that perks me
the most because I'm white right yeah
because my skin is white al is black
let's say because the skin is black
you're Brown right because your skin is
brown okay what is wrong with being red
are they red are you brown is he black
and my wife nobody's the exact [ __ ]
color I'm for sure Brown you're upset
because you don't have America anymore
that's the thing like it's not about red
skin or being called Indian or Native
America and any of that kind of it
please be honest it's not about that
everything about America is offensive
Native Americans not the [ __ ] name
Redskins but we don't even know if
they're actually offended because none
of us know any Native Americans we're
all just guessing yeah any surveys on
some [ __ ] newspaper yeah none of us
knows a Native American to even ask yeah
so it's just a bunch of white people
trying to cover their [ __ ] asses
right and this is real this is the real
[ __ ] that this is is like I've realized
what the [ __ ] these things are we did a
piece kind of about it last week but we
touched on a little bit but this way it
is all the heads of these organizations
all white right Hollywood 93% right only
white in the executive roles I think the
Nike executives we looked at it was a
hundred percent while every one of these
businesses right now every football team
guaranteed like us and the executive
roles they don't want to lose their jobs
right so they're like you know we got to
get the smoke off us if we don't do some
some pander and diversity [ __ ] right now
they gonna realize that we've been only
hiring white people for executive
positions only promoting white people
executive positions they gonna realize
who the real racists are out here brah
they gonna figure out that we've been
creating this little boys and girls
white Boys and Girls Club just for us if
we don't throw out some races little
cars or whatever some chips or whatever
the [ __ ] it is I don't know
make it rain you make a rain with
singles now hundreds yeah here's no
morsels exactly Don these feel Me's
[ __ ] they'll keep eating right and
all these all of us just strippers out
here gobbling up all these little rolls
oh my god you stop being cartoon
characters thank you so much oh my god
you're gonna stop calling the Redskins
window real root of the issue right it's
putting a bandaid on [ __ ] artery
that's severed
yeah right it's like you gotta you gotta
cauterize that artery like that worked I
was a jay-z to call so you got to go you
got to take care of the [ __ ] artery
but they understand what's going on in
that artery and they're like we cannot
let [ __ ] know executives on
Holly we can not let [ __ ] know
how [ __ ] goes on are they hateful of
black people no do they want black
people get shot by the cotton no none of
these things do they like hiring their
friends that all happen to be y
absolutely right do they like looking
after their people and create a nice
little canoe just like anybody would in
their situation absolutely do they care
about diversity enough to hire people
that don't look like them and they're
not in their little friend Club No
so how do they get the smoke off them
you could be Bart Simpson you we're
gonna change the name of the Redskins
but we don't forget who all the
producers of The Simpsons are even Lord
Simpson they're gonna pretend or they're
gonna forget
I'm Matt Groening white ass or whoever
else white people behind the camera
mm-hmm and castellan or whatever and
here's the thing it's okay that's what
they do people realize it's okay you're
allowed to be able to white people to
own a business right now fact this is
America if the majority of people are
white majority the people their own
business is probably gonna be white
that's they're allowed to do that what
it when it's not okay is when you do the
performative diversity [ __ ] and you get
on your [ __ ] high horse and act like
you're this like leader of this new
progressive movement and then you go
back to your office because then you
take away our ability to judge what
you're doing fairly but devoid of and
objectively yes then we get if you stop
give do this pandering performative [ __ ]
we can look at your positions and say oh
is that a company I want to still
support or go to Reebok that's less fire
but maybe they got some black people in
or that yeah now you're just giving me
something I can be like oh yeah
okay look all eyes matter their black
lives matter they got the Kapernick
billboard yeah let's keep buying Nikes
yep
Disney doing that same [ __ ] right what
Disney being ahead of that cart for
years dog what they do they were always
mad diverse if you ever watch like oh
you're trying to make up for [ __ ]
wall just anti-semitism yeah and also
I'm pretty sure they did that clamp
movie or some [ __ ] like that
they did a claim what we think so I
think so Song of the South something
like that yeah yeah yeah what was that
are you talking about x-men they get a
movie about the clue I need to say it ku
klux that's what you know they're not
Supremes a Ku Klux or klu klux mark you
would know most like white supremacy
[ __ ] is the brand Supremes sneakers a
super look they got they literally they
don't do nothing they don't change
nothing they just take a glass and
they're like but now it's supreme why is
it better and they're like well because
we are in it what color are the letters
what of supreme what color the letters
on white and what are they built on
Native America white of red cream is for
Trump no [ __ ] oh hey what color is kiss
logos I don't know white white on black
background black lives matter black
lives matter flip side you know can I be
honest with you I don't not only do I
think the Redskins should keep their
name I think I should make it more
racist go I think this is the perfect
like racism that reminds people racism
exists but hurt anybody yeah it's not
financially [ __ ] people over is
physically [ __ ] people over yeah but
if they were like the Washington [ __ ]
white skinheads
you could be like yo racism still exists
huh hurtin anybody but it still exists
interesting so it like shines a light
in a way that like it's the Home Depot
Center yeah the American Airlines Center
for racism that's it so you put that
Britain to all lives matter arena yo the
Chicago Black Lion Black Hawk lives
don't man that's what I'll talk about
you have the Indians are murdered so
yeah so what's the Cleveland Indians you
can't even call them Indians I don't
even know brother thing about so on that
why how do we name so much [ __ ] after
Native Americans like what was going
through if we're so racist I don't know
like if the people back then was so
racist why they name in everything after
natives no taking on the Cleveland
Indians it's like internet like taking
down a statue of a Confederate soldier
like you're doing that because that's a
bad person the Indian is is he a bad
person that y'all sound it's the team
reminding you all we don't come conquer
your [ __ ] yeah you wouldn't name
yourself after the conquered it's a
weird strategy in Nashville Nazis it is
a weird strategic thing that would be a
fire team that would beautiful the [ __ ]
out she'll be hot I like that process
they burn all right but not for real you
would name it after the victor true
right right which is Cleveland blankets
sneezes is weird like part of me that to
me shows you how foul we must have been
to Native Americans nah we'll be going
hey ask my
huh I thought this Alaska Native
Americans yeah what's up this all mexi's
do is repopulate back what's theirs next
news is a Native American remix the
remix is hot yeah it's so hot I'm gonna
cross the ball across the river in Texas
just cuz it's hot they just want to take
a little dip in the pool imagine that
you just trying to take a little dip
current man rough yeah you end up on the
other side you suppose have not get out
back the other way
choppy ass can call me a [ __ ] I'm
tribal but for real man it's something
so we need to get a Native American
expert on here
dude I'm saying is there a Native
American expert you better get a [ __ ]
was it guys to do the excavation the
fossil [ __ ] that's why we need
paleontologists that's how we combine
extinct species in America nice if we
got Native Americans they endangered at
least you think they are brah that's a
Snow Leopard of humans you know they're
all like name themselves up to like
animals that [ __ ] like she's like
running claws nobody was like my chief
immune system now this is this
being broke this thing I got we are
talking Native Americans dead acid I
truly want to know how y'all feel about
like white people just [ __ ] being
horrendous to you wiping all out and
then name in every street after y'all
like naming all these teams I feel like
that's an odd thing to do wierd thats
wierd thats wierd thing to do you know
how do you even feel after the fact
maybe they took the land and they're
like oh whoa
remind you guys that like this was your
land even maybe that was the little
white move back in the day [ __ ] that
you never you drive it down channel Oak
Street and you're like man we use the
own like tearing off the [ __ ]
band-aid we need a native of a listen if
you're Native American your [ __ ] army
you're part of the gang holler at us I
know we've got a couple dudes are from
Arizona they always come out to the
shows when we're in Tempe so if you
listen right now dear me I need to know
the history of this [ __ ] I really need
to know how the Native American
community feels about one the Redskins
to the Blackhawks to all the Braves all
these Native American things and three
I'm you know why the [ __ ] something's
hateful or not red skin black skin white
sand white skin brown skin gay like what
the [ __ ] Ark so why are you translucent
you trans skin yo mark mark explain it
to me mark use that [ __ ] brain of
yours yeah I was trying to like that
[ __ ] I like um funny nothing right I
think it was the way it did you look up
Native Americans or did you look
[Laughter]
this website it said no search results
do they have a boxer they got right in
you really fell hope when they take away
your box or on the census website they
still got a boxer and they yeah fill in
a couple of boxes to try to make it you
know like what it's like when you try to
make purple with like red and blue you
got to just put him where where your
people exists man is [ __ ] anyway so
basically there's no reason why nobody
spoken about I can't find it but
apparently everything's named after
Native Americans half the states got
their names from Native American
Minnesota Oklahoma Oklahoma Texas I did
I think is the Cossack yeah there's a
valley for Nia that's probably it right
yeah mainly I don't know so we got
nothing bro babies I'm gonna get it to
his wife yo you my main oh you're you
think that's what it was yeah now he's
known about ours here called Oh horses
hair is mainly when it looks like a
horse what the place on the side I'll be
honest I don't know what main looks like
me neither
I don't know Vermont is and I don't know
New Hampshire is I don't know none of
them that whole area up there Boston
Boston be honest is New Hampshire a
state or not no New Hampshire I'm
shocked is that a state it's a province
it's a state it's a province we are
geographical Jesus on this show any
stain is i'ma tell you go North Dakota
in America
it's also north probably North to South
Dakota
what was it above South Dakota I did go
where's Virginia east of hey I could get
there if you get me to Virginia
[Laughter]
stupid-ass [ __ ] States with names
with the direction wait till you get to
my theory about kidnappers your state
has the direction in its a show it can't
be that's the main [ __ ] yeah North
Dakota South Dakota West Virginia what
else is there you know what I think
South Carolina North Carolina Oh true
okay back to the risk of New Jersey only
reason why we need to go to a do a tour
of all the old like your go to your that
I should be fired I want to go to Jersey
where's York I want to go to England I
think York's in England okay they're all
in England I thought is Jersey in
England that upset is all Jersey in
England I think out of it yo I'll be
honest I think New Mexico is the only
nudist more trash than ours
if I'm being honest like New York bodies
York yeah oh yeah bodies it for sure
right not New England
yo New England step it up you lop stayin
[Applause]